cabott is the support class he provides
the team with a tactical advantage the
damage amplifier multiplies all damage
delivered to the target by your
teammates dust tagging covers a large
area in radioactive dust that outlines
all creatures caught inside the rail
cannon emits an instantaneous blast that
can blow through objects and damage
creatures on the other side remember to
use supports cloak ability ladies and
gentlemen boys and girls hunters of all
ages and monsters of all stages this is
DB Sinclair here with J party and I'm
excited to be back TV we are back and we
are watching evolve this is Game one and
we've got a special treat for the ladies
and gentlemen out there J party we've
got some new hunters that's right we're
looking at our new content at a
particularly Cabot and this matches who
already were following him you see that
new ability that does tracker it's used
a lot like the barrage we've seen before
on Hank but this is gonna be used to
track a huge area and mark all the
creatures in it so that team can catch
up and look like that catches the
monster on the first one there with that
huge AoE yeah nicely done by the support
you see a big blast of green dust and
then everything in the vicinity they're
turning yellow even the wildlife lucky
catch on the monster we're gonna see the
monster outlined for a while they're
gonna know right where he's headed right
now you're seeing him use that railgun
trying to actually shoot him through the
rocks jparty this weapon is a slow
weapon to shoot but it can't damage
through barriers as you can see there
and they get him right in the film yeah
that piercing ability is so cool it
allows you to go through walls or
objects in space pretty much anything
that gets in its way as it tries to find
its target here hoping to connect with
the monster and that thing's gonna hit
like a truck when it does connect
speaking of the dome J party we've got
the new trap
and he's going Adam with that shotgun
they're trying to do damage look like
they're tangling with an elite pro
BellSouth that could be a good damage
pickup her even the hunters or the
monsters as Abe tries to lock down
Goliath with those stasis grenades
jparty
absolutely there yeah that does create a
high-priority target right in the middle
of this fight you're gonna see a lot of
contention for this upgrade is that
damage perk is such a big addition for
any squad here we'll see which one kids
and I like what the hunters are doing
here they're just rotating by trying to
pick up that perk without getting out of
position err they're doing a great job
so far yeah nicely done by support this
support character Kabat he is a wide
range support character who's mostly
literally supporting the rest of the
cast with what he does he helps to track
her track with the dust taggi and he
helps assault do damage with the damage
amplifier and then he also helps do
damage himself with that railgun and
then finally he has the group cloak
where he can help with the sort of
defensive get out of the way of the
monster activity there so you see him
leading the pack here he could do that
with that cloak if the monster turned
around on him for whatever reason he'd
be able to cloak himself and get out of
the way looks like they found the
monster we've got Goliath here on the
fusion plant and jparty so far so good
by the hunters yeah great first fight
Goliath already an app elf here and that
was thanks to Cabot Matt best tracker
doing a great job here shooting that
across these large open areas though it
won't really be a big disadvantage for
the hunters of the nails Goliath again
you saw that small flash of green that's
gonna let the hunters know exactly where
he is in that real-time relentlessly
fire it through these rocks such a cool
combination of abilities on this hunter
yeah nice dust tagging it allows you to
see your enemies all out through the map
not just the monster obviously the
monsters your primary target but you
could see that the mammoth birds and the
creatures like the croco sloth
potentially who you don't want to mess
with they're gonna be outlined and
visible as well to the hunters ya wide
range of uses for the ability do you
have to watch out there that is a quite
a long cooldown on it so once you miss
you're gonna have to wait
that comes up off cooldown monster to
stage two as we saw there they found him
right away he's in the cocoon coming out
stage two no armor gets hit right away
by support who gets a nice cloak to stay
away from the monster the monster on the
run trying to hit through rocks not
really having the confidence in his
actual shooting abilities jparty
now that can be a little rough those
one-shot weapons the monster also going
on the run here doesn't like look at
that encounter and that's a good
decision here you got caught right out
of a cocoon and that is the most
susceptible time as a monster you're
gonna don't want to run get at least
some base armor here start jumping over
to our new trapper classes you see in
some of those stasis grenades that's
gonna slow down a large area who the
monster crosses one there you're gonna
see those blue ranges get on him once
those are on the monster it's gonna
greatly slow his actions reduce his
jumps and overall make it a lot easier
for your team to just get that damage
down on the monster
yeah really hard to move when you have
two spaces grenades really hard to jump
the monster doing well though to lock
them down here this is not a good place
to fire a very unfortunate dome although
if they could get that perfect to trade
that damage bonus for a health
regeneration they might not need that
right now J party as the monster is
doing work yeah this tyrant is such an
important bonus here these hunters do
not want to lose this fight if they're
driven out of this area and all the
monster to get health regen all that
work they've done is gonna be completely
null and void and the rest of this match
yeah they are working with Val here so
they do need to see some peels from Val
Val does have a Down penalty so that
could pay big dividends dividends for
the monster here in the late game and
right now he is just taking advantage of
them stacking up right now and doing
massive damage to the whole team
supports trying to use that damage
amplifier there but unfortunately the
team just isn't a simple enough to get
real concentrated fire up on the monster
for a little bit scattered here as they
try to find cover and allow the medic to
get some healing off on the weaker
members of the team you see that damage
amplifier on the monster coming in from
support as jparty mentioned as the
trapper here Abe tries to do damage with
the damage amplifier up he's using that
shotgun the shotgun at
one shot at a time will fire a accurate
slug into the monster it fired rapidly
as you see there it's gonna be more of a
spread like a buckshot a down goes a oh
and that's actually a twofer there as
two hunters are dropped in this fight
but doesn't like the look of it as he's
down to just do bars of hell that stage
- not a lot and with the assault still
in the fight it's not something he looks
like he wants to engage on a nice free
meat snack to take on there as the
monster gonna see the potential of
another does tagging here it looks like
he's gonna be able to knock it down
there he sees the monster in the
distance potentially tagging him they're
making him visible for the rest of the
team as he's moving off here let's see
if that's a smart move jparty definitely
wants to stay two by two in this team of
hunters yeah gonna be dangerous to go
alone here you're definitely one to
split up in that pincer the to be to
maneuver but I like the decision here
from the support trying to spread out
looking for a big open area as he gets
eyes on the mullet a little bit he gets
taken down by a venom on there and
that's just so disrupting the collector
vision and slower movement as well as
poisoning you over time yeah toxic
poisons from the wildlife not fun to
deal with let's say you missed on that
previous dust tagging he's gonna try it
again here and this is a good time to do
it he'd get the side of the monster the
monster glowing red looking like he's
got about full armor jparty
oh and a great shot here marks the
Goliath they're gonna go to see him for
a while here oh it gets the hit on that
boot on that rifle - doing some good
damage on the monster just wearing down
that armor that's so important to keep
pressure on the Goliath you don't want
to allow him to get to that full armor
every little bit of damage you can do is
just so important yeah keeping him on
the run and keeping him visible is gonna
allow the team to split up and do that
pincer maneuver like you mentioned if
they have visual on them they know
exactly where they need to do in their
teams of two that was a little fortunate
there the dust went down just as Goliath
evolved which means he can't be getting
these real gun shots through that wall
which is unfortunate as this is such a
good time to get damage off the Goliath
now at stage three poses a big threat
open they get the arena off on the fresh
out of the cocoon Goliath and this is
gonna be a big moment for the team
hopefully they can assemble quick enough
yeah nicely done by the trapper he is
separated from the group it looks like
they are finally catch
now monster down to half health as you
could see there that is the trapper
ability right so Abe has that as well
and it's down though J party as we
mentioned before on the show if you go
down as the trapper down comes your
mobile arena and that is unfortunate the
team was just a little too fragmented
Goliath is able to focus fire the first
hunter before the rest of them can get
there for support hopefully hopefully
the support though can get this revive
off and get the team back into the fight
he had a cloak so he wasn't visible
while running from the Goliath he is
able to get the trapper back up trapper
down on two strikes now J party and so
is assault with big-time rock throw such
a good rock through Knox is sold out of
this match even with medic still feeling
I'm it's gonna take a while here and
it's gonna give it a life room to
breathe as that major source of damage
is now knocked out of this fight as you
can see the stasis grenades stay in the
air even if the trapper goes down
Goliath ran through one there was
temporarily tied up but he is just able
to pick his targets now down goes
another hunter medic is down assault is
down support and trapper trying to stay
alive in this plant looking we're off
once you're off your rocker like this
it's so hard to recover the team is
sewed based around having that synergy
and working together as people fall here
it's gonna be hard for them and I think
this is the time where the hunters need
to split up fall back and try to recover
for the next fight
trapper is dead it looks like the medic
and support work cloak there but the
monster gets eyes here comes another
rock it's gonna miss let's see if they
could stay alive J party he's a good
combination right now at least with no
shield though from Hank
so no Hank in the game which means no
shield he's gonna have to try and stay
alive he already popped his cloak
earlier he's the last one alive now and
just like that it's Cavitt burst apiece
and this is not looking good here as his
cloak is a long away from cooldown oh
what a nice man that's what he needs to
do here stay all wrong
but he can't dodge that as a blow to the
face takes a Bentley I loved the running
punch there the punch from midair nicely
done by the monster to finish this team
ladies and gentlemen that's Cabot and
Abe throwing down
on the fusion plant here and evolve I'm
TVs Eclair that was jparty with me on
behalf of 2k internal rock thanks for
watching and we'll see you next time